hoping to stop another West African coup
in its tracks niger's Western backers
and the regional block ecowas have
Frozen millions of dollars in Aid and on
Sunday Chas president Idris Debbie met
with niger's ousted leader Mohammed
bazoom and separately with coup leader
abdulrahman shiani in an effort to end
the crisis
I am not able to tell you what they have
discussed you have seen president Debbie
he has met with the president and with
the purchase and what I can tell you is
that at the end of these meetings he
returned to Chad so I believe that very
soon we will hear about the conclusions
of these meetings what I know is that
everything is in place for the
Constitutional order to be
re-established as soon as possible such
measures may include the use of force
bus it's the threat of direct
intervention that has alarmed niger's
military on Sunday ikawas threatened to
use Force unless civilian rule was
restored within a week and coup leaders
have accused France which has thousands
of troops in nesia of plosing an attack
that's been denied by Paris neighboring
Mali and Burkina Faso themselves
governed by military juntas have rallied
around the officers who ousted president
bazoom foreign
we refuse to apply these illegal
illegitimate and inhumane sanctions
against the people of Niger we warn that
any military intervention against Niger
will be considered as a declaration of
war against Burkina Faso and Mali
the U.S hasn't announced any sanctions
so far instead offering niger's military
time to reverse course we haven't made a
determination yet because it is still an
ongoing fluid situation it is clear that
there has been an attempt to remove
president bazoom from Office it's not
yet clear that attempt will ultimately
be successful so U.S assistance hinges
on continued Democratic governance in
Niger
end of niger's military isn't swayed by
The Exodus of much needed Aid it'll
likely be felt by the millions of people
living in one of the world's poorest
countries Alex beard Al Jazeera
well Cameron Hudson is a senior
associate at the center for strategic
and International Studies he says the
treatment of the deposed president is
not what you would typically expect
I've been saying this from the beginning
I mean he's been uh he has a telephone
that telephone is reportedly being
monitored by the Junta but he's able to
receive calls so he's received uh in the
last few days calls from the Secretary
of State uh our U.N Ambassador other
world leaders uh he has tweeted uh on a
number of occasions essentially saying
that democracy would be restored in in
Niger so uh not not at all like uh a
typical coup where he has been asked to
sign a resignation paper normally they
don't go through the process of of
demanding that a head of state resigns
simply uh the fact that uh that the coup
has taken place uh is sufficient uh
typically and so I think what that's
doing however is it's creating this
moment uh where countries like the
United States are not prepared to
declare this coup over and and a sort of
Fayette complete uh by the military
which is why I think we have not seen a
kind of Declaration from Western
countries that this clue that this coup
has done I think countries like the
United United States and France are in a
very difficult position right now
because if they walk away from this coup
if they sort of throw their hands up and
say that the coup is done and they do
that too quickly it will really look
like an abandonment of one of the kind
of bright uh Democratic examples in the
region and sent send very bad examples
to other uh struggling democracies
across the continents